véritable cri de détresse quand charline
la nièce delta découvre la terrible
réalité sa tante est atteinte de la
maladie d'alzheimer
sur scène trois actrices pour faire
ressortir tous les drames autour de mâle
qui concerne la bien des familles
martiniquaises
eliane dracius dans le rôle de la nièce
thérèse meyer dans celui de la fille et
flora géré mais la maman comédienne est
aussi auteur de la pièce rédigé après un
énorme travail de documentation ce qu'il
en ressort
l'extrême solitude des familles quand on
est seul canton 6 avec le malade parce
que certaines personnes ont toutes deux
leurs proches qui sont malades et pour
les protéger donc s'enferme deviennent
prisonniers et de la maison et du malade
et souvent il y a des aidants qui
meurent avant les aider le malade vit sa
vie et ce sont les aidants qui subissent
être les dents pour un alzheimer
c'est très difficile parce que on est à
bout on est excédés ils nous sollicitent
il nous il nous maltraitent du genre en
algérie les joints des rivières je pense
que c'est une pièce qui est nécessaire
surtout pour les gens qui ont tour les
gens en les aidant parce que sa crête un
petit peu de cette problématique de
l'évolution de la maladie au sein d'une
famille et de l'impact de cette
de cette maladie sur les gens qui
entourent ce le malade
une pièce qui a touché le public présent
c'est un travail qui est pas gratifiant
je veux dit
c'est un travail dur mais il faut
l'aimer il faut me les personnages
à l'heure actuelle je dis que ce travail
ce genre de travail c'est un travail
dans les aidants au besoin le soutien au
sujet dramatique qui a pourtant fait
sourire sourire vite crispé car la
réalité c'est que nul n'est à l'abri du
fléau d'alzheimer dans notre île
[Applaudissements]